calculemos cuánto es 4 enteros cuatro
quintos entre un entero un médium pausa
el vídeo intenta encontrar la respuesta
y te daré una pista intenta reescribir
estos números mixtos como fracciones
impropias ok vamos a trabajarlo juntos
cómo podemos escribir cuatro enteros
cuatro quintos como una fracción
impropia bueno podemos ver esto como
cuatro enteros más cuatro quintos y
darnos cuenta de que 4 es lo mismo que
20 quintos entonces me quedan 20 quintos
más cuatro quintos lo cuales 24 quintos
otra forma de pensarlo es tomar este 5
que es nuestro denominador y
multiplicarlo por el entero en este caso
el 4 5 por 4 es 20 ya eso sumarle el
numerador en este caso 4 20 + 4 es 24
quintos
tengo 24 quintos entre y hagamos lo
mismo para un entero un medio un entero
un medio es lo mismo
que uno más un medio y bueno un entero
es lo mismo que dos medios más un medio
me da tres medios muy bien ya
reescribimos nuestra expresión como 24
quintos entre 3 medios ahora la clave es
saber que esto es lo mismo que 24
quintos por el recíproco de tres medios
cuál es el recíproco de tres medios
pasos el vídeo y descubre lo bueno para
obtener el recíproco de tres medios
simplemente hay que cambiar el numerador
con el denominador y nos quedará dos
tercios ahora cuál es el resultado de
esta multiplicación bueno una forma de
hacerlo es multiplicar los dos
numeradores y obtener 48 y multiplicar
los dos denominadores y obtener 15 lo
cual nos dará 48 entre 15 y después
reducirlo hasta su forma simplificada
otra forma de verlo es escribiéndolo así
esto es lo mismo que 24 por 2
entre 5 x 3 y con esto vamos a
simplificar lo más que se pueda antes de
hacer la multiplicación puedes ver que
24 y 3 son ambos divisibles entre 3 así
que déjame dividirlos ambos entre 3 24
entre 3 8 y 3 entre 3 es 1 ahora sí
podemos multiplicar los denominadores y
los numeradores y obtener como numerador
8 por 2 lo cual es 16 y como denominador
5 por 1 lo cual es 5 entonces tenemos 16
quintos y si quieres expresar esto con
un número mixto tenemos que observar que
5 cabe tres veces en 16 y sobra 1 nos
quedan 3 enteros un quinto y bien ahora
puedes ver que simplifica en este paso
de aquí hay otras personas que
simplifican en este paso de camps y
dicen pueden ver que eventualmente
tendré un 24 en el numerador y un 3 en
el denominador así que voy a dividirlos
ambos
324 entre 3 8 y 3 entre 3 es 1 hay veces
que a esto se le llama una
simplificación cruzada pero es
exactamente lo mismo que lo que hicimos
nosotros en el siguiente paso bueno ya
tenemos la respuesta así que nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo